La première fois que je suis partie à l'UMD de Cadillac, j'avais peur.
UMD, ça veut dire unité pour malades difficiles.
On y soigne ceux qui sont dangereux pour la société.
A 40 kilomètres de Bordeaux, celle de Cadillac
est l'une des plus anciennes.
Depuis 1963, c'est une forteresse.
Des murs de trois mètres de haut doublés de grillages.
Derrière, 90 patients,
Seulement des hommes, enfermés de force.
Chaque sortie et chaque entrée sont strictement contrôlées.
Pour pénétrer dans ce monde clos,
Un monde dans un monde,
Il faut un badge magnétique
et franchir le double sas de sécurité.
Pourtant la première chose qui frappe quand on entre ici.
"La porte est
Ouverte."
C'est le silence.
37 000 mètres carrés de cours grillagées et de bâtiments.
Au début, on s'y perd.
Les malades sont répartis dans cinq unités.
Dans l'une d'elles,
il y a un homme qui vient d'arriver.
Philippe a 50 ans.
Il vivait seul dans une petite ville de l'ouest de la France.
Avant, il était facteur.
Mais il sentait bien que quelque chose
n'allait pas chez lui.
Un jour, il a failli tuer.
J'ai des flottements dans la tête.
C'est à dire ?
Il y a quelque chose de pas stable
dans mon esprit et dans ma tête.
J'ai agressé mon voisin avec une arme blanche.
J'aurais pu aller en prison,
J'ai été déclaré irresponsable dès le début
parce que j'avais mon délire.
Je projetais des fantasmes sur une personne,
mais à points très élevé.
C'était pour une femme ?
Oui.
Je pensais qu'il était un obstacle à ma relation avec elle.
Il était une interférence.
Parce que je prétendait communiquer avec elle par télépathie.
Et quand je voulais m'adresser à elle,
C’était lui qui répondait
à travers la cloison du plancher
C'était qui cette femme ?
Une assistante sociale.
Elle m'a crevé les yeux.
Quoi ?
Elle m'a dit "Je t'aime" avec les yeux.
Hélas, tout ça, c'est faux.
La femme et moi, nous n'avons pas de relation.
Vous regrettez ce que vous avez fait ?
Oui.
J'ai pas voulu le tuer.
Il m'avait rien fait, ce voisin.
C'est pas de bol pour lui de tomber sur moi.
Comme Philippe, en France,
600 patients sont hospitalisés
dans des unités pour malades difficiles.
Certains ont alimenté des faits divers retentissants.
Ces actes font d'autant plus peur,
Qu'on ne les comprend pas.
La plupart de ces meurtriers n'ont pas eu de procès.
La loi considère qu'on ne peut pas juger,
Ceux dont le discernement
était aboli au moment des faits.
C'est pour eux, qu'à la fin des années 40,
on a créé ces lieux.
Entre prison et hôpital,
Leur protocole de soins est intensif,
Leur cadre hyper sécurisé.
Dans les chambres, les meubles sont scellés.
Cet univers quasi carcéral,
ce n'est pas pour les punir,
Mais par nécessité.
Tout pourrait servir d'arme à ces hommes.
Parce qu'ils sont tenus au secret médical,
Les soignants n'ont pas le droit de nous dire
pourquoi les malades sont là.
Alors ce sont eux qui nous ont raconté leur histoire.
Au sein de l'UMD, nous avons installé un studio,
Et ces hommes qui ont du mal à s'exprimer
se sont livrés.
La plupart sont sous tutelle.
Ils ont négocié le droit de se montrer.
Les autres, nous les avons filmés dans la pénombre.
Nous avons changé leurs prénoms.
En fait, on va parler de ce que vous souhaitez,
Tout ce que vous souhaitez, on parle.
Pendant des mois, nous avons partagé leur quotidien.
-Allez ! C'est bon !
-Me pousse pas !
-Je ne te pousse pas, je te motive !
Nous avons découvert comment leurs psychiatres
les ramènent à la réalité.
J'ai des tocs en ce moment, je suis pas bien,
j'ai des tocs.
Leur face à face avec le juge,
Leur dernier recours pour être libéré.
Moi j'ai tué personne, j'ai volé personne.
J'ai oublié d'encaisser des lotos
et la France des jeux me les a volés.
Nous avons rencontré des mères désemparées,
Quand elles ont découvert la maladie de leur enfant.
Je l'ai vu se battre comme ça dans le vide.
Il me disait "Couche toi, maman, ils vont te faire mal."
À l'écart de la société,
Ces hommes passent parfois des dizaines d'années
au sein de ces unités.
Prisonniers des murs, mais aussi de leur folie,
Nous avons voulu savoir qui ils sont.
Avant la construction de l'UMD, dans la région,
Cadillac était déjà célèbre pour ses fous.
La ville, qui compte 3000 habitants,
Peut accueillir plus de 800 malades mentaux.
On en croise souvent dans ses rues.
Ils sont soignés à l'hôpital psychiatrique
situé en plein centre.
Depuis toujours,
Son histoire est liée à celle de la folie.
Au XVIIIᵉ siècle,
On l'appelle l'asile d'aliénés
et il reçoit ses premiers patients.
Des nobles tombés en état de démence,
Enfermés ici à la demande de leurs familles.
En 1918, ce sont d'anciens poilus.
La société ne sait pas quoi faire
de ces hommes revenus traumatisés du front.
À l'époque, on ne sait pas les soigner.
Le cimetière de la ville
porte les vestiges de cette histoire.
Avec son carré, appelé celui des fous,
Ou encore celui des oubliés.
900 croix alignées,
La plupart sans pierres tombales.
Aujourd'hui, on ne sait plus très bien
qui est enterré là.
L'unité pour malades difficiles,
A été construite le long de ce cimetière.
Là-bas, tous les matins, c'est le même rituel.
Il est presque 8h,
L'heure de réveiller les patients.
Bon allez, c'est parti !
Ils ont passé la nuit
enfermés à clé dans leur chambre.
Bonjour Messieurs.
Répartis en dortoirs de 4,
Dans ce bâtiment, ils sont 16.
Ils viennent de toute la France,
Ils ont entre 24 et 68 ans.
Avant de les filmer,
Nous avons passé du temps avec eux sans caméra,
Pour faire connaissance
et qu'ils s'habituent à notre présence.
Certains sont imprévisibles.
Leur maladie les a entraîné si loin,
Qu'ils ont besoin d'une surveillance
et de soins spécifiques.
À l'UMD, c'est un luxe en psychiatrie,
Il y a 1 soignant pour 6 patients.
Les infirmiers sont au plus près des malades.
Ils partagent leur quotidien.
Le réveil est un moment essentiel.
Il permet de capter l'humeur du jour
et de fixer le cadre dès le matin.
Ça va Monsieur Dutheil.
On veille à ce que le patient nous dise bonjour,
Nous regarde dans les yeux,
Des petites choses comme ça quand même.
On vérifie si ça va bien se passer ensuite.
Pour nous, c'est un moment de prise de contact,
C'est un moment d'observation,
Donc on regarde en fait,
Et puis on voit s'ils sont bien organisés,
S'ils choisissent bien leurs affaires,
S'il n'y a pas de tension entre eux,
S'il est bien réveillé,
S'il n'est pas trop triste,
Il y a plein de choses.
On s'est dit bonjour ?
Il est super bien fait votre lit,
je ne suis pas sûr de faire aussi bien.
Comment ça va vous, aujourd'hui ?
Il paraît que c'était dur hier ?
Oui, ça a été dur hier.
Et là aujourd'hui, ce matin ?
C'est un peu dur.
Oui, c'est dur,
Mais vous y arrivez quand même.
Allez ça va bien se passer,
comme tous les autres matins.
Depuis qu'il est tout jeune,
Daniel souffre de troubles obsessionnels compulsifs.
Dans le passé, ces tocs l'ont rendu violent.
Ça fait 11 ans qu'il vit dans cette unité.
Ici, c'est l'un des plus fragiles.
Ce matin, il est encore plus angoissé que d'habitude.
Peut-être à cause de la présence
derrière lui de Karim.
Les pouces levés,
Lui est à Cadillac depuis 6 mois.
C'est l'un des plus agités du groupe.
Bonjour Monsieur le cameraman.
Excité par la caméra,
C'est en tout cas celui que l'on entend le plus.
On voit.
Donc pour moi, il y a trop de bruit.
Ça résonne et ça peut gêner certains patients.
Il ne fait rien de mal,
Mais ça peut gêner.
Chez certains, la maladie se manifeste
par des hallucinations auditives.
Autrement dit, ils entendent des voix.
Pour eux, le bruit,
encore plus que pour nous,
Est un facteur de stress.
Parfois, il y en a qui demandent à rester 1h au calme,
En chambre d'isolement,
Car ils ont peur d'eux mêmes
et de ces sons qui résonnent.
Les autres vont prendre leur petit déjeuner
dans le réfectoire.
Pour rythmer la journée, aucune sonnerie,
Mais des portes qui se ferment toujours à clé.
L'emploi du temps, chaque jour le même,
est millimétré.
Comme les médicaments,
Cela fait partie de la thérapie.
Ce rapport au temps permet
d'ancrer les malades dans la réalité.
Le moindre changement d'habitude
risquerait de les perturber.
C'est encore plus vrai pour les patients
qui souffrent de troubles obsessionnels,
Comme Daniel.
Et Daniel vous arrêtez là ?
Quand il était petit,
On ne connaissait pas sa maladie.
Il nous a raconté qu'à l'hôpital,
On disait à ses parents :
"Votre fils est juste cinglé".
A 48 ans, il n'a jamais pu construire sa vie.
Bon appétit.
Il ne souffre d'aucune pathologie physique,
Mais il est malade depuis tant d'années,
Que, peu à peu, son corps est devenu le reflet
de son cerveau chaotique.
Ce qui les a amenés ici,
Ce sont des angoisses incroyables,
des souffrances incroyables.
Ils ont eu des vies fracassées,
ils ont pu en fracasser aussi.
Donc on essaie de les accompagner et
de soulager ce qu'on peut et puis voilà.
Daniel doit gérer ses propres symptômes,
Mais ici, il doit aussi supporter ceux des autres.
Les règles strictes,
Les mêmes pour tous,
Rendent possible une vie en communauté
qu'ils n'ont pas choisie.
Monsieur ****, vos lunettes de soleil s'il vous plaît.
Monsieur, on vous parle là,
C'est pas parce qu'il y a le médecin que voilà...
Les lunettes de soleil on les récupèrent,
Parce que vous jouez avec,
Et vous n'avez rien à faire avec dans le service,
Vous pourrez les récupérer dans la cour
et encore si ça se passe bien.
Mais il y a des moments ou la moindre contrariété,
Rend insupportable cette cohabitation forcée.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe Daniel ?
Je suis un peu découragé parce que
ma mère m'a pas appelé,
Quand elle m'appelle pas, moi ça me rend
anxieux, triste, triste.
Et puis en plus, je suis en colère contre Karim,
Je peux plus le voir ce mec, je peux plus le sentir.
Je crois bien qu'un jour je vais le canner, je vais lui foutre une branlée.
Il va comprendre sa douleur.
Attention à ce que tu dis, Daniel,
Déconne pas non plus, tu sais où t'es ici...
Tu sais où t'es ici, attention à tes propos.
Je sais que tu vis avec un passé comme ça,
hyper violent, mais t'as changé.
Ça fait un moment que tu n'as pas mis un tir à quelqu'un.
Ça fait combien de temps ?
Tu sais combien de temps ça fait
que tu t'es pas énervé,
Contre un soignant ou contre un patient ?
Ça se compte en mois, en jours ou en années ?
En années.
Voilà. Donc pendant tout ce chemin,
T'as appris qu'il y avait des alternatives,
Plutôt que mettre des coups à des patients
qui t'énervent de trop.
C'était quoi ces alternatives ? Tu les connais.
Sinon, tu ne serais pas là aujourd'hui.
C'est quoi ?
Discuter avec les infirmiers.
Tu as conscience qu'à ce jour, ton problème,
Ce n'est plus la violence,
c'est les tocs ton problème.
C'est les tocs.
Et là t'as la violence qui refait un peu surface.
Ben oui, à cause des tocs.
A cause des tocs de pas avoir eu ma mère au téléphone.
Comme Daniel,
La plupart des patients ont des problèmes d'élocution.
Les traitements et les troubles mentaux
ralentissent les mouvements.
Ils altèrent aussi les capacités d'organisation,
La concentration, la mémoire et l'apprentissage.
Pour les préserver,
L'UMD propose des ateliers d'ergothérapie.
Ergothérapie, ça veut dire soigner par l'activité.
Hors du cadre formel des unités,
Ces travaux manuels permettent aussi de libérer la parole,
Et d'occuper l'esprit à autre chose qu'à la maladie.
Sur accord médical,
Les patients ont même le droit à l'outillage.
C'est mon meilleur jour, le lundi,
quand je vais au jardin.
J'adore le jardin ! Ça nous défoule, ça nous détend.
Les malades choisissent leur activité.
Stéphanie fait partie de l'équipe d'ergothérapie.
Tous les jours, elle va les chercher,
Car ils n'ont pas le droit de sortir seuls
de leurs unités.
Bonjour Yann, ça va ?
Très bien.
Je vous emmène en activité.
Jean-pierre vous prenez votre manteau.
Daniel !
Pour Daniel et les autres, ces rendez-vous,
Allez-y !
C'est un peu comme une bouffée d'air frais.
Stéphanie travaille ici depuis 15 ans.
Le plus important pour elle,
C'est la confiance mutuelle,
Qu'elle a progressivement réussi à instaurer
avec les patients.
La clé de la serrure qui frétille !
Ma petite Stéphanie de Monaco !
Vous pouvez pas me rassurer d'avantage ?
Impressionnée à ses débuts,
Elle nous confie qu'elle n'en a jamais eu peur.
Bon, Jean-Pierre,
Il va nous en faire trois tonnes Jean-Pierre !
Depuis toujours,
Jean-Pierre adore jouer les divas.
C'est rigolo.
On raconte même qu'autrefois,
Il était une icône de la nuit bordelaise.
Il y a encore votre pinceau à nettoyer.
Ah bon.
Quand il vient ici,
Il aime se souvenir de sa vie d'avant.
Moi, j'ai réalisé une statue de Michel Polnareff,
Avec les lunettes.
Et en bas j'ai marqué "Night club",
Parce que je travaillais avant dans des clubs,
J'étais Disc Jockey. Voilà.
Et en haut, c'est mon nom.
Pollux, c'était votre nom de scène, d'artiste ?
Oui.
Pour ces hommes rejetés et stigmatisés par la société,
Fabriquer des objets dont ils sont fiers,
C'est retrouver un peu d'estime d'eux-mêmes.
Mais l'accès à ces ateliers,
Ne leur est permis qu'après
plusieurs semaines d'observation.
Vous vous rappelez comment on fait ?
Ce n'est que lorsque les médecins
et les infirmiers estiment qu'ils sont prêts.
Attention à vos doigts.
Attention aux miens aussi.
On les autorise à utiliser des outils,
Même les plus tranchants,
Et ça n'a jamais posé problème.
C'est bon maxime.
Nous avons tous les outils dans le placard,
Les ciseaux, les cutter, tout dans le placard.
Alors si on était dangereux,
Comme on dit, comme on le répète,
Et ben on aurait pris un truc,
Ben non !
On montre qu'on n'est pas tout ça,
Qu'on est des dangereux et ci et là,
Et ben non, c'est pas possible !
Moi j'ai des tocs en ce moment.
Je ne suis pas bien, j'ai des tocs.
Ah bon ?
Oh, **** !
Et ben !
Moi ce que je peux vous dire,
C'est que j'ai raté ma vie à cause des tocs.
Vous les avez depuis quel âge ?
Des tocs ? Ouais,
Depuis ma naissance.
Vous avez quoi comme tocs ?
Des paroles, d'actes, de pensées.
Quoi, vous répétiez la même chose ?
Oui voilà, comme les portes...
Fermer, ouvrir, ouvrir, fermer.
Mes parents,
C'est pas une croix qu'ils ont portée avec moi,
C'est trois un croix.
Parce que j'ai fait des tentatives d'assassinat,
des tentatives de suicide...
On ne sait pas qui Daniel a tenté d'assassiner.
C'était il y a longtemps,
Mais il sait qu'il a toujours besoin d'aide.
Jean-pierre, lui, est un délinquant sexuel.
Parce qu'il n'a jamais tenté de tuer,
Il ne veut pas comprendre ce qu'il fait là.
Moi, je veux qu'on montre que je ne suis pas
tout ce qu'on dit.
Non mais c'est vrai,
Il y a des gens qu'on enferme un peu comme ça,
Voilà un peu arbitrairement. Voilà.
On enferme mais en même temps,
on essaie de les aider.
Ah non!
On enferme plutôt pour les détruire,
Parce que la société ne veut pas accepter
les mots qu'on dit.
Et oui !
Les maux, MAUX ?
Allez-y !
Hospitalisé en psychiatrie depuis plus de 10 ans,
Jean-Pierre en est à son huitième séjour en UMD.
Depuis qu'il est revenu ici il y a un an,
Il multiplie les recours,
Contre une hospitalisation qu'il considère
comme abusive.
Cet après-midi,
Il a demandé un entretien à sa psychiatre.
Le docteur Floris le suit depuis 3 ans.
Quand les patients quittent l'UMD,
Ils retournent dans leur hôpital psychiatrique d'origine.
La dernière fois qu'on a laissé sortir Jean-Pierre,
Au bout de seulement 5 jours,
Il aurait de nouveau agressé un patient.
L'entretien a lieu en présence
d'une interne et d'une infirmière.
Vous allez bien ?
Oui ça va.
Asseyez-vous, je vous en prie.
Je n'en peux plus d'être à l'UMD,
j'étais coupé de tout monde extérieur.
C'est une violation de mon droit.
Il aurait fallu que vous ne repassiez pas à l'acte,
Et vous ne seriez pas revenu à l'UMD.
Et oui, le problème,
Il est quand même là au départ.
Je suis désolée,
Mais vous n'êtes pas revenu par hasard à l'UMD.
Après, vous êtes suffisamment intelligent,
Pour être capable de travailler sur votre problématique.
Le problème, c'est qu'à ce jour,
Vous ne l'acceptez pas ou vous l'acceptez
un jour sur deux.
Je travaille sur moi.
Oui. Ah bon ?
Mais non, mais tant mieux.
Je travaille sur moi,
Comment je peux stopper ça,
Comment j'arrive à stopper mon impulsion.
Donc ce qui est quand même intéressant
dans ce que j'entends,
C'est que si vous travaillez sur vous-même,
Pour essayer de mieux gérer votre pulsion sexuelle,
C'est que vous vous identifiez, qu'elle pose problème.
Pose problème,
vous savez on a toujours besoin de...
Mais ce n'est pas d'avoir des envies sexuelles
qui pose problème.
On l'a déjà travaillé ensemble ça.
C'est normal d'avoir des envies,
C'est après comment on les gère.
Vous avez des difficultés à interpréter
les choix de l'autre.
Les ?
Les choix de l'autre,
Dans la position de l'autre.
Parce qu'on en avait parlé,
C'est pas parce qu'il vous dit
bonjour et qu'il vous parle,
Qu'il est intéressé pour aller plus loin, tout ça.
Non, il était d'accord.
Je ne crois pas une seconde,
Que vous avez été suffisamment naïf pour penser,
"Oh si, il est d'accord"
Vous saviez quelque part,
Qu'il n'était pas forcément d'accord,
Mais qu'il n'allait pas s'opposer.
Donc au bénéfice du doute ça se tentait.
On est d'accord,
Il n'y avait pas de méchanceté
ou d'hostilité en soi là-dedans.
Sauf que vous ne mesurez pas,
Que ça peut être extrêmement traumatisant
pour la personne en face.
Parce que vous vous substitué à son propre désir,
Vous supposez que le désir est partagé.
Mais là, vous vous êtes juste trompé,
À nouveau trompé.
Donc ça s'appelle ?
Une agression sexuelle.
Le problème est beaucoup plus vaste
qu'un simple problème de libido.
Il y a une quête affective
très importante derrière tout ça.
Très franchement,
Moi j'ai du mal aujourd'hui à me projeter,
Dans l'idée d'envisager qu'il ait suffisamment évolué pour le faire sortir.
On pourrait dire,
Allez, on lui laisse encore une chance,
Mais lui laisser encore une chance, c'est quoi ?
C'est tant pis, il y aura une autre victime,
Mais on lui aura laissé une autre chance.
Ça fait 8 fois qu'il vient,
c'est le huitième séjour.
Et les médicaments ne peuvent pas l'aider ?
Je pense que non.
On a des médicaments pour contrôler les hormones,
Mais je pense que ça ne changerait rien.
Il se sentirait à mon avis dévalorisé,
Diminué, castré...
Je crois que là, pour le coup,
Le peu de lien qu'on a réussi
à construire avec lui, on le perdrait.
C'est parfois compliqué de distinguer
ce qui relève de la maladie,
De ce qui est lié à l'histoire,
Et à la personnalité des patients.
Dans les UMD, la plupart sont atteints de psychoses,
Des pathologies psychiatriques qui entraînent
une distorsion de la réalité.
Leur origine est mal connue.
Elle serait en partie liée à un déséquilibre,
Des molécules chimiques,
Qui communiquent par électricité les informations au cerveau.
Ces molécules, ce sont les neurotransmetteurs.
Ils gèrent entre autres le sommeil,
L'agressivité et l'humeur.
Chez les psychotiques,
Ces molécules peuvent transmettre
de faux messages au cerveau.
Il y a plusieurs types de psychose,
Mais la plus fréquente ici,
c'est la schizophrénie.
Réduite à tort à un dédoublement de la personnalité,
Elle est en réalité plus complexe.
La schizophrénie,
C'est une maladie qui fait qu'on perd
complètement le sens du réel.
On croit que quelque chose est vrai,
Alors que c'est une coïncidence hasardeuse.
On croit ressentir les choses,
On croit entendre des voix.
J'entends des voix,
Je suis tellement seul des fois que je repense à mes amis,
Et je leur parle dans ma tête.
Et je parle à mes potes comme si j'étais au téléphone.
Je dis "Alan, comment ça va ?"
Il me dit "comment ça va ?"
Et ça continue comme ça tout le temps.
Vous parlez tout fort ?
Non, je ne le fait pas, parce que c'est mal vu ici.
Outre ses hallucinations,
La schizophrénie se manifeste par des comportements
et des idées bizarres,
Ce qu'on appelle les délires.
Parfois, ils prêtent à sourire.
J'ai mis en culture des espèces d'insectes,
Dans le genre des trèfles dorés,
Et il y a un autre insecte qui avait une espèce de crête jaune,
Avec un corps rouge et des pieds bleus.
Je vous assure que c'est pas des schtroumpfs !
Et ma mère en a mangé un,
Et ça l'a rendue complètement folle.
Mais il faut comprendre que les patients
croient réellement que ce qu'ils vivent est vrai.
Coupés du monde,
Dans une autre réalité qui les isole des autres,
Certains se renferment complètement sur eux-mêmes.
Ce qu'ils ressentent et entendent
peut être terriblement angoissant.
Il y en a qui ont la sensation de pourrir sur place,
D'autres qui sont pris dans des délires de persécution.
Ils me piègent, je vous ai déjà dit ça, qu'il me piégeaient.
Quand je suis arrivé là-dedans, j'étais pas malade,
j'étais pas schizo.
Ils ont tout fait pour me rendre schizophrène.
C'est de la torture.
Quand je suis à table, il parle de moi.
Ah ils m'en veulent, mais je sais pas d'où c'est parti ça,
Pourquoi ils m'en veulent comme ça.
Je ne comprends pas, moi.
Je suis tout seul contre tout ça.
Ils me matraquent, ils me matraquent.
Murés dans leurs certitudes,
Souvent les patients n'ont pas conscience d'être malades
et qu'ils ont besoin d'aide.
Mais s'ils sont ici,
C'est qu'à un moment donné,
Leur folie a atteint quelqu'un d'autre
et qu'ils ont eu des gestes de violence.
Pas mal ce que vous avez fait.
Dans les unités, comme ici à l'ergothérapie,
Les soignants essayent de les ramener doucement à la réalité.
Pour vous, vous êtes malade ou pas ?
Non, pour moi j'entends juste des voix.
Mais ce n'est pas un endroit où d'après-vous,
Vous auriez dû être parce que vous n'avez pas votre place ici ?
Non.
Si vous deviez dire, dans quel contexte,
Pour quelles raisons vous êtes arrivé ici ?
Sans faire exprès, j'ai cassé 2 côtes à une infirmière.
Sans faire exprès cassé 2 côtes ?
Voilà, c'est ça, sans faire exprès,
Je l'ai poussé contre le lavabo et je lui ai cassé 2 côtes.
Et j'ai tiré les cheveux d'une infirmière.
Et alors, quel regard vous portez là dessus ?
Ben du dégoût, parce que je suis dégoûté de moi,
D'avoir fait l'enfant comme ça.
Ça m'aurait évité l'UMD.
Parce que c'est vraiment ça que mon médecin m'a dit.
Plus un, où j'ai cassé ma chambre.
Ça fait quand même 3 épisodes.
Plus quatrième épisode,
Un coup de poing que j'ai donné à mon pote dans la figure.
Donc du coup, ces épisodes de violence vous les attribuez à quoi ?
C'était par inadvertance.
Et qu'est ce qui vous dit que ça ne va pas se reproduire ?
Je le sais, je n'ai jamais été violent sans ça.
J'ai bien vu le taux que j'avais atteint pour arriver là.
Vous comprenez que le médecin du service d'origine,
Et les médecins qui sont ici,
Qui vont se prononcer sur votre sortie,
Aient besoin de garanties par rapport à ça ?
Vous le comprenez ou pas ?
Non, je le comprends pas.
Faire prendre conscience aux patients de leur maladie,
Et de la gravité de leurs actes
peut prendre des années.
Affronter la réalité est parfois trop dur à supporter.
Chez les schizophrènes,
Le suicide est la première cause de mortalité.
Il y a 20 ans, Pierre a tué sans raison une infirmière.
Quand il a recouvré ses esprits et réalisé ce qu'il avait fait,
Il est tombé en profonde dépression.
Ça s'est passé dans un foyer thérapeutique,
Et elle était à la cuisine,
et là elle m'a crié dessus.
Ça m'a rappelé une maîtresse quand j'étais petit,
Qui était sévère...
Et je l'ai tuée.
J'ai pris le couteau de cuisine et je l'ai plantée.
Mais je pensais pas que je l'avais plantée à 5 coups.
J'étais jeune, j'avais 22 ans à l'époque,
Et je m'en veux,
Et ça m'a bouleversé ma vie,
Ça m'a bouleversé.
Je l'aimais bien cette personne,
On allait au cinéma, on allait au restaurant.
Et c'était une personne bien !
Et moi j'ai disjoncté.
Je fais avec,
Mais j'ai toujours cette douleur qui me touche.
Des fois je pleurais parce que je croyais qu'elle allait pas mourir,
Qu'elle était immortelle.
C'est dur, c'est dur de vivre avec un mort sur les bras.
Je regrette oui, elle ne méritait pas ça,
Maintenant, elle, elle est sous terre.
Trop malades pour être soignés
dans des hôpitaux psychiatriques ou être incarcérés.
Tous ces hommes ont été placés en UMD à la demande du préfet.
Pour en sortir,
C'est une commission de psychiatres indépendants qui se prononce.
Mais depuis quelques années,
La justice aussi peut intervenir.
Aujourd'hui, Michel a mis sa veste du dimanche.
Il est à Cadillac depuis 2 ans,
Et il va justement tenter de convaincre un tribunal
de le faire libérer.
L'audience doit avoir lieu à 200m à peine de l'UMD,
Mais c'est le protocole :
Pour prévenir tout risque d'évasion,
Chaque trajet doit s'effectuer en ambulance,
Avec la présence d'au moins 2 soignants.
Et le préfet doit en être informé 48h à l'avance minimum.
Des mesures de sécurité trop contraignantes,
Pour conduire les malades jusqu'à Bordeaux.
Michel a rendez-vous à l'hôpital psychiatrique de Cadillac,
Où une annexe du tribunal a été aménagée.
Deux jours plus tôt,
Nous l'avions rencontré dans son unité.
Il a 46 ans,
Il n'a pas commis d'actes graves,
Mais son état est si délirant,
Qu'il perturbait son hôpital psychiatrique d'origine.
Persuadé d'avoir gagné une fortune au loto,
Et qu'on l'empêche de toucher ses gains.
Tout de suite, il donne le ton de l'entretien.
Vous n'avez pas d'interférences là ?
Non je crois pas.
Parce que ma mère m'avait dit qu'elle avait fait mettre,
par le dentiste du centre de Marne,
Une dent à micro.
J'ai des paroles en permanence de gens,
Comme si j'avais une oreillette.
Qui me disent ****, **** !
Pire qu'un téléphone où on reçoit des spams
parce que là je ne peux rien régler.
Quand vous entendez des voix,
est-ce que vous pouvez leur répondre ?
Oui, il y a un dialogue qui se fait.
Mais c'est pas une folie, c'est pas une folie.
D'aussi loin qu'il s'en souvienne,
Michel est toujours passé d'hôpital en hôpital.
Il ressent l'audience d'aujourd'hui,
Comme un moment capital.
Depuis 2011,
Les passages des patients devant la justice
sont obligatoires tous les 6 mois.
Ils permettent de s'assurer qu'on n'enferme pas
les malades à tort.
Ce sont les juges de la liberté et de la détention
qui y veillent.
Il statuent sur tout type d'hospitalisation forcée,
En hôpital classique comme en UMD.
L'année dernière, en France,
Près de 100 000 patients ont été internés contre leur gré.
Les juges n'ont aucune formation psychiatrique,
Mais ils servent de garde-fous,
En contrôlant que les droits des patients sont respectés,
Par des médecins qui autrefois étaient tout puissants.
Michel est assisté d'une avocate commise d'office.
Allez-y !
Bonjour.
L'audience est publique.
Tout le monde a le droit d'y assister.
Bonjour.
Mais moi j'ai tué personne, j'ai volé personne.
J'ai oublié d'encaisser des lotos,
et la Française des Jeux me les a volés.
Vous savez que vous êtes dans une unité bien particulière ?
Moi je suis d'accord pour sortir.
Et vous vous sentez prêt à sortir complètement de l'hôpital,
Ou à sortir juste de l'unité ?
Complètement de l'hôpital.
Et donc si vous sortiez, ce serait pour aller où ?
Ce serait pour aller au château de Divonne.
C'est quoi ce château ?
C'est un château à Divonne,
Que je pense que ma mère a dû acheté.
Enfin faut que je vois avec les notaires,
Parce que ma mère est morte, mon père est mort,
mes grands parents sont morts,
Mon grand père m'avait laissé 2500 millions,
Ou 2 milliards 500 000 millions.
Je comprends pas,
Vous iriez dans le château dont vous auriez hérité,
Mais vous êtes sûr qu'il est à vous ?
Je ne suis pas sûr et certain,
Mais de toute manière, il est ouvert au public,
c'est un hôtel.
Très bien, vous voyez d'autres choses à m'expliquer ?
Oui, j'aimerais me marier et ne pas sortir à 110 ans.
Quand vous dites que vous voulez vous marier,
C'est que vous avez déjà quelqu'un ?
Oui, j'ai plusieurs personnes.
J'ai de la famille proche qui voudrait m'épouser,
Mais c'est toujours délicat dans ce cas là
parce qu'on est proche de l'inceste.
Mais bon, c'est des petites cousines,
Et des petites copines que j'ai eues, qui sont sympas.
Très bien. Merci Monsieur.
À l'UMD, Michel ne reçoit jamais de visite.
On ne connaît pas sa famille.
Par ici.
Oui je sais que c'est à gauche.
L'audience a duré 20 minutes.
Moi je croyais qu'il allait y avoir des petits fours !
Michel se détend.
L'essentiel aujourd'hui,
C'est qu'on l'ait écouté.
Bonne fin de journée,
et puis j'espère qu'on va réussir à sortir.
La juge a rendu sa décision dans l'après-midi,
Elle a maintenu Michel à l'UMD.
Depuis qu'elle statue sur les hospitalisations sous contrainte,
Elle n'a jamais décelé d'abus à Cadillac.
Dans les unités pour malades difficiles,
La durée moyenne de séjour est de 8 mois,
Mais pour certains, c'est presque toute une vie.
A 41 ans,
Éric n'a jamais été marié, il n'a pas eu d'enfant.
À l'UMD, il a un statut particulier.
Responsabilisé par la justice,
Il a été condamné à 20 ans de prison
pour actes de barbarie.
Il purge ici sa peine.
Ça fait 11 ans,
11 ans que je suis enfermé en UMD,
Et 15 ans que je suis enfermé.
J'étais en prison avant.
Et pourquoi vous avez été transféré de la prison en UMD ?
J'étais irrationnelle, j'ai eu un comportement étrange.
Je n'étais pas comme tout le monde.
Et on vous a dit ce que vous aviez quand vous êtes arrivé ici ?
Oui, je suis schizophrène et bipolaire.
Moi, je pense que la maladie,
je la traîne depuis pas mal de temps.
Vu l'enfance que j'ai eue.
J'avais beaucoup de problèmes à extérioriser
ce que je ressentais.
J'avais un double moi, c'est ma maman qui dit ça.
Les premiers symptômes d'Éric apparaissent
à la fin de l'adolescence.
Il commence à fumer du ****,
Une **** dont on sait aujourd'hui,
Qu'elle peut révéler une schizophrénie
chez certains sujets fragiles.
Peu à peu, il s'enferme dans un autre monde
et se marginalise.
J'avais un appartement, un travail, une amie.
Mes parents qui me soutenaient.
Une famille.
Et puis, du jour au lendemain,
Je suis parti,
un moment d'égard où je me suis orienté vers les ****,
Et j'ai été foudroyé,
Par cette ****.
Quand leur enfant est schizophrène,
Ce sont toujours les parents qui sont en première ligne.
La schizophrénie est une maladie encore mal connue,
Qui fait peur.
Souvent, ils ont honte d'en parler.
A une centaine de km de là, en Charente.
La mère d'Éric, elle,
A eu le courage de témoigner à visage découvert.
Framboise !
Claudia est très proche de son fils,
Même dans les pires moments.
Elle ne l'a jamais lâché.
Je l'ai partout, il me suit partout.
Je l'ai là.
Il est là,
Voilà mon Eric, à chaque fois que je viens là,
J'ouvre, je lui parle.
Voilà, il était tout jeune, heureux,
très heureux. Happy !
C'était un petit garçon joyeux ?
Très, très joyeux !
Joyeux et aimant,
Très doux, très intelligent,
Très doué, doué en tout.
Les parents d'Éric se sont séparés quand il était petit,
Avec sa sœur Agnès et sa mère,
Ils forment un trio fusionnel.
Claudia est infirmière.
Elle ne roule pas sur l'or.
Mais il ne manque ni d'argent ni d'amour.
Il a 16 ans quand tout commence à déraper.
Il avait une petite amie parisienne,
Qui fumait, qui se ****, qui se ****.
Et puis, petit à petit, Eric a suivi le mouvement.
Voilà, j'ai été très longue à m'en rendre compte,
très longue...
Jusqu'au jour où je l'ai vu se battre comme ça dans le vide,
Il me disait :
"Couche toi, maman, ils vont te faire mal !
Couche toi, couche toi, ils sont là, regarde,
ils ont des couteaux."
Là, ils avaient des hallucinations et là, j'ai compris.
Claudia comprend que son fils se ****,
Mais elle l'ignore encore qu'avec ces hallucinations,
C'est la maladie qui commence à s'exprimer.
Éric arrête ses études et sombre dans la petite délinquance.
Un jour de Noël, il ne reconnaît plus ni sa mère ni sa sœur.
C'était plus lui.
Il nous a pris pour des voleuses.
Moi, j'étais une femme qui voulait venir voler l'âme de sa mère.
Donc Agnès m'a défendu parce qu'Éric m'a frappé.
Il a pris une fourchette à rôti et il a frappé sa sœur,
Il lui a mis la main dans la bouche pour qu'elle ne crie pas.
Il lui a planté la fourchette à rôti dans la gorge.
Et ma fille était enceinte,
Elle a perdu son bébé.
Donc tout ça, ce sont des choses très difficiles.
Agnès a voulu protéger son frère et n'a pas porté plainte.
Pendant des années,
Claudia a vu le calvaire des parents
qui ont des enfants différents.
Elle cherche du secours auprès des pouvoirs publics
et des institutions,
Mais personne ne semble pouvoir l'aider.
Les pompiers me renvoyaient vers la gendarmerie,
La gendarmerie, dans un hôpital,
L'hôpital me disait : "Consultez le médecin avec lui."
En fait, je tournais sans arrêt, sans arrêt.
Son fils fait peur.
Même ses amis l'abandonnent.
Je ne pouvais plus compter sur personne.
Et quand j'en parlais, on disait :.
"Écoute met le, à la porte, ne lui donne pas à manger
il reviendra pas".
Il y a une personne qui m'a dit un jour :
"Mais moi je le fusillerai si j'avais un fusil, je le fusillerai".
Et plus on me disait ça, plus j'avais envie de l'aider,
Je voulais qu'il s'en sorte.
Je l'ai vraiment porté à bout de bras, à bout de bras.
Il aura fallu presque 6 ans,
Avant qu'une psychiatre ne pose un diagnostic,
Et annonce à sa mère que son fils est schizophrène.
Le monde s'est écroulé,
Le monde s'est écroulé !
Elle s'est levée de son siège,
Elle m'a prise dans ses bras,
Et elle m'a dit :
"Vous savez, contre la schizophrénie,
Il faut absolument que votre fils accepte de se faire soigner".
Mais il est majeur, il ne veut pas.
Donc il n'y a qu'une chose, c'est attendre,
Malheureusement, qu'il fasse du mal à quelqu'un.
Emporté par sa folie,
Un jour, Éric se met en tête qu'un ami de la famille
veut du mal à sa mère.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Mais croyant la protéger,
Il va chez lui et lui plante un couteau dans l'oeil.
J'ai pris de l'****, j'ai bu du vin rouge,
Et je suis rentré chez lui,
Et j'ai agi.
J'ai décompensé tout simplement.
Ça veut dire quoi décompenser ?
Décompenser, c'est perdre toutes ses possibilités
mentales et physiques.
J'étais dans le néant.
Je vivais dans un néant.
Mais il est mort ?
Non, il n'est pas mort.
Je me suis retrouvé condamné à 20 ans de prison.
Ils m'ont assaisonné,
J'avais 27 ans.
Ce tableau a été offert à l'UMD par sa mère.
Quand il est arrivé ici,
Eric était trop malade pour avoir
des contacts avec l'extérieur.
Elle trouve ce moyen de lui faire savoir,
Qu'elle est toujours là.
C'est ma maman qui l'a fait.
Derrière, il y a un poème qui dit :
"Mon Eric, j'espère que ce petit présent te fera du bien au moral,
Pendant ton absence.
Ta maman qui t'aime et qui pense toujours à toi
même très loin géographiquement".
J'étais touché.
Son intention était incommensurable.
Je le remet à sa place.
Celui là je le prendrai quand je partirai.
Ça vous a fait quoi de le savoir à l'UMD ?
Ça m'a soulagé, vraiment soulagé.
Je savais que plus personne pouvait lui faire du mal,
Et que lui non plus, en fait,
N'aurait plus fait de mal à personne.
J'ai eu la chance d'avoir une maman comme ça.
Et de l'avoir toujours ?
De l'avoir oui.
Elle a eu pas mal de problèmes,
Et je fais partie de ses problèmes,
En grande partie.
Est-ce que vous ne lui avez pardonné ?
Moi oui, j'ai pardonné.
Agnès, elle me dit :
"Je l'aime, j'aime mon frère".
Elle est allée le voir quelquefois,
Mais maintenant qu'elle a ses 3 enfants,
Elle veut les protéger.
Et elle revoit la scène quand il lui a mis
la fourchette à rôti dans la bouche,
Qu'il voulait la tuer.
Mais elle me demande toujours des nouvelles d'Eric.
Elle lui fait des cadeaux pour son anniversaire, son Noël.
Mais elle a peur, même s'il est en lieu sécurisé,
Elle a peur.
Elle ne veut plus, elle ne veut pas le voir,
elle ne peut pas.
Enfin soigné,
Eric n'a plus de délires et ses médecins estiment
qu'il n'est plus dangereux.
Mais pour pouvoir quitter l'UMD,
Il doit demander une libération conditionnelle à la justice.
Il saura bientôt si elle est acceptée.
Le vendredi, c'est le jour de la cantine.
Un terme hérité de l'univers carcéral.
À tour de rôle,
Les patients vont récupérer ce qu'ils ont pu commander,
Et acheter avec l'autorisation de l'équipe médicale.
Vous avez un versement tous les mois ?
Non en fait, je dois voir l'assistante sociale pour lui demander.
Parce que là, vous commencez à être vraiment ric rac.
La plupart vivent d'allocations adultes handicapés,
Soit environ 800€ par mois.
2 gels douche...
Avec cette somme gérée par leur tutelle,
Ils peuvent se procurer leurs produits d'hygiène et leur tabac.
Un, quatre, cinq.
Mais aussi de quoi améliorer l'ordinaire.
Ici, c'est l'un de leurs seuls plaisirs.
Un chausson aux pommes,
Et 2 Montecristo.
Oui.
Merci.
Philippe, l'ancien facteur s'est offert des cigares.
Peu à peu, il s'habitue à son nouvel univers.
Pendant ce temps, Daniel,
Le patient qui souffre de tocs, est en entretien médical.
Féru d'information, il a 2 passions :.
La politique et le sport.
Dans sa chambre, il peut écouter la radio jusqu'à 22h.
Mais c'est la Coupe européenne de football,
Il voudrait suivre le match de ce soir jusqu'au bout.
Les matchs de football sont beaucoup plus tard,
Que mes horaires de radio le soir.
Est-ce que je peux l'avoir jusqu'à 23h30, mon poste ?
Qui joue ce soir, quelle équipe ?
L'équipe de Razgrad, équipe bulgare,
contre le Paris Saint Germain.
Et hier soir il y avait Séville contre Lyon...
Daniel, on passera le mot aux veilleurs ce soir.
Et oui, les veilleurs, qu'ils me laissent le poste
dans ma chambre jusqu'à 23h30.
D'accord, d'accord, oui, il n'y a pas de souci.
Et oui ! Sinon, je vais pas pouvoir écouter le match en entier !
Ça marche, ça c'est calé. On a réglé cette question.
Vous me promettez que ce soir,
je peux écouter jusqu'à 23h30 ?
Est-ce que j'ai déjà répondu à cette question ?
-Oui.
D'accord. Donc c'est bon ?
Vous ferez le mot aux infirmiers ?
Vous vous endormez, vous êtes fatigué ?
Non je suis pas fatigué, je suis pensif...
Quand Daniel a une idée fixe,
Il peut poser la même question pendant des heures.
J'ai rien compris. Redressez-vous et essayez d'articuler
parce que là je ne comprend rien.
Merci.
Je voudrais jusqu'à 23h30 le poste de radio...
Ça marche, pas de soucis.
On fait comme ça. Vous pouvez regarder le foot.
Parce que l'autre fois, il y a eu un match,
je connaissais même pas les scores parce que
je n'avais pas mon poste radio.
Daniel, qu'est-ce qu'on a dit ?
On a dit que c'était possible d'aménager
les horaires pour ce soir.
Allez, on s'arrête là parce que vous allez
me redemander une fois de plus et je vous ai déjà répondu.
Ok ? Bonne journée, on se revoit bientôt ?
Ces idées obsessionnelles,
C'est un peu comme une forteresse mentale,
Qu'il se serait construite pour se protéger des angoisses.
Le psychotique, c'est comme s'il lui manquait
une enveloppe entre lui et le monde, qui régule.
Il se retrouve finalement complètement explosé et morcelé.
Même les limites corporelles sont difficiles à percevoir,
les limites psychiques encore plus.
Et lui a mis en place une espèce de défense,
une espèce d'armure en fait,
Constituée par tous ces rituels, tous ces tocs, tout ça,
Qui contient bien sa psychose,
Donc le but, ce n'est pas non plus de fragiliser cette armure,
Parce qu'elle lui est quand même très utile,
mais elle l'enferme en même temps.
Donc il faut réussir à trouver un compromis,
Pour que ça ne le contraigne pas trop,
Que ça ne l'empêche pas non plus de vivre et d'évoluer,
Mais en respectant ses défenses, parce que ses défenses,
elles lui sont extrêmement utiles,
Elles évitent l'explosion.
La médecine ne sait pas encore guérir les psychoses,
Mais elle sait en contrôler les symptômes.
C'est bientôt l'heure du coucher,
Et les infirmiers préparent les médicaments du soir.
Tout ça, ce sont des neuroleptiques ou des antipsychotiques.
Pour ajuster les doses au plus près,
100 gouttes.
La plupart des médicaments se donnent
sous forme de solution buvable.
Donc là, vous avez un neuroleptique et un antipsychotique.
Les neuroleptiques et les antipsychotiques,
Ce sont des tranquillisants super puissants.
Mais ici, on essaye de soigner sans assommer.
C'est quelque chose qui va permettre de contrôler,
Les hallucinations et de contrôler,
Le délire du patient
et éventuellement son état de tension.
Sans ces médicaments,
Les patients risqueraient de passer de nouveau à l'acte.
3 fois par jour,
Ils les prennent sous la stricte surveillance
de l'équipe soignante.
Merci.
Suivant.
Cédric, là.
Oui.
Ça va mieux.
Bon, c'est le principal, si ça va mieux.
Comme le diabète ou l'hypertension,
Les psychoses sont des maladies chroniques
qui nécessitent un traitement à vie.
Mais la difficulté de ces pathologies,
C'est de le faire comprendre à des malades qui souvent
n'ont pas conscience de l'être.
Sans savoir ce que j'ai, tu maintiens mon traitement,
Je trouve que c'est presque une atteinte aux droits de l'homme.
Mais tu as le droit d'avoir tes idées, je les respecte.
Là, c'est pas le moment de les déballer.
Donc je te propose, je suis là demain matin,
on se voit en entretien pour en parler.
Est-ce qu'on peut forcer un patient à prendre ses médicaments ?
C'est toute la difficulté de notre travail.
Ils sont à la fois, juridiquement, ils sont sous contrainte.
Mais à la fois, est-ce qu'on peut vraiment forcer ?
Alors je veux être honnête avec vous,
On ne cherche pas à forcer,
Mais on va essayer de le convaincre
que c'est dans son intérêt de le prendre.
On va lui mettre la pression, on va lui dire :.
"Mais si vous continuez comme ça,
Et si vous êtes menaçants et si vous refusez vos traitements,
De toute façon, c'est prévu,
On n'a pas besoin de demander votre avis,
On a une injection qui est prévue,
On a un isolement qui est prévu,
On a des contentions qui sont prévues.
Dans ce couloir, 2 chambres d'isolement.
Ce jour là, elles sont vides.
Ici les soignants privilégient toujours
la pédagogie à la force.
C'est ta prescription.
L'une de leurs premières missions,
C'est d'éduquer ses hommes à leur maladie,
De leur apprendre à vivre avec.
Le but,
Qu'ils continuent leur traitement à l'extérieur,
En acceptant les effets secondaires.
Problèmes de poids ou d'élocution.
Ils sont importants mais dépendent de chacun.
Le valium, c'est systématiquement le soir ?
Oui.
Et un si besoin l'après-midi ?
Alors à partir d'aujourd'hui, tu l'as plus.
Avant de trouver le traitement le plus adapté
à chaque patient,
Il faut tester plusieurs médicaments.
C'est un travail de longue haleine.
Grâce à ma nouvelle molécule, je suis content.
Ça a changé ma vie.
Comment vous dire,
J'ai la tête en fait, avec les médicaments,
Qui jouent sur le cerveau.
Ah ils me font vraiment beaucoup de bien.
Ça me fait planer ça, ça me met...
Mieux qu'un ****.
Dans le hall, Daniel a son poste de radio,
Mais il est de nouveau pris par ses tocs.
Les médicaments ne font pas toujours des miracles,
Mais ils arrivent à soulager ses angoisses
et c'est déjà beaucoup.
Avant de monter à l'étage,
Les patients récupèrent à tour de rôle
leurs affaires pour la nuit.
L'hôpital met à leur disposition des pyjamas,
Ils achètent le reste de leurs vêtements
via la cantine,
Ou lors de sorties thérapeutiques.
Moi, je préfère les miennes !
Totalement pris en charge,
Les malades font parfois penser à de grands enfants.
Bon Daniel, c'est quoi le protocole ce soir ?
Il faut tout poser à sa place ?
Donc là, t'as quoi à faire Daniel ?
Prendre ta douche ou pas ? C'est demain matin ?
Non, demain matin la douche.
Ok bon ben c'est réglo alors.
C'est pour ça que j'ai mis ma serviette là.
Ok.
D'accord, ça marche.
Allez go !
Non, allez dépêche-toi, c'est bon.
Les infirmiers, incarnent l'image parentale qui rassure.
Aller, ça va pas bouger, Daniel.
Mais qui doit aussi savoir sévir quand il le faut.
Avant, Jean-Pierre se teignait les cheveux en blond
pour ressembler à Michel Polnareff.
Ici, c'est interdit.
Mais il a voulu se poser un masque capillaire.
On ne va pas passer toute la nuit avec ça sur la tronche ? Mais.
Je le laisse agir toute la nuit, je le rince le matin.
Vous laissez ça toute la nuit ?
C'est dégueulasse, tu ne vas pas te coucher avec ça.
Monsieur, mais vous allez vous rincer les cheveux.
Dépêche-toi s'il te plaît.
Qu'est-ce que vous attendez ?
-Et ben j'attends...
Mais la plupart du temps, tu te laisses aller
et tu te comporte comme un punk.
Et là, ce soir, tu nous fais un masque de cheveux !
T'es pas là, d'habitude je le fais.
Ça m'étonnerait, c'est pas possible !
Mes collègues ne te laisseraient jamais te coucher
avec une tonne de crème sur la tête.
Et alors ?
Le moindre incident,
Comme celui qui vient de se produire
avec Jean-Pierre est consigné.
Ainsi, toute l'équipe médicale est au courant.
Tous les soirs,
Les malades sont enfermés dans leurs chambres,
Pour protéger les autres,
Mais aussi pour se protéger d'eux mêmes.
Les Lumières doivent s'éteindre à 21h précises.
Quoi ?
Ne me pousse pas !
Je ne te pousse pas, je te motive !
Allez, dors bien Jean Pierre, à demain.
Est-ce que vous rêvez la nuit ?
J'avais rêvé que mon lit se décollait du sol
et qu'il passait par la fenêtre,
Et je me baladais comme ça dans l'air.
Qu'est-ce qui vous manque ici ?
Un laboratoire, des souris, et puis...
L'affection !
Il y a plein de choses qui me manquent.
Quoi ?
L'amour !
Et oui, comme tout le monde, je suis un humain !
Je rêve plus en fait, je rêve plus, non.
Alors j'essaye de rêver les yeux ouverts mais... Voilà.
La nuit, les angoisses se réveillent.
Le manque d'amour d'une femme,
Le manque d'amour d'une mère,
Les souvenirs qui reviennent
et qui ravivent les pensées suicidaires.
Ce soir là, les infirmiers sont spécialement inquiets
pour un patient.
Il est en chambre seul maintenant ?
Oui en chambre seul et il dort avec le minimum de tentation
pour se stranguler.
Il n'y a pas de taie, pas de draps.
Il nous demande d'enlever,
tout ce qui lui permettrait de se stranguler.
Parce qu'il joue au jeu du foulard.
Dès qu'il est trop angoissé,
Qu'il n'arrive plus à gérer, il se strangule.
Et là, en ce moment, il le fait beaucoup, beaucoup.
Donc de lui même, tout ce qui peut l'aider à se stranguler,
Il nous le donne pour ne pas le faire.
Briefée par les infirmiers de jour,
L'équipe de nuit a pris le relais.
Le patient qui se strangule pour soulager ses angoisses,
S'appelle Florent, il a 28 ans.
Il est ici depuis seulement 7 mois.
Mais depuis toujours, sa vie est émaillée d'ultra-violence.
À l'âge de 16 ans,
J'ai pris la tête de quelqu'un,
J'ai pris sa tête et je l'ai éclatée contre le béton.
J'ai fait ça parce que voilà.
Il avait fait du mal à une amie que je respectais beaucoup.
Je l'ai défiguré.
Ce déchaînement de violence cache souvent
une enfance cabossée et un lourd passé psychiatrique.
Soigné pour des troubles graves du comportement
dès l'école primaire,
Florent est malade depuis tant d'années,
Que ses intenses souffrances psychiques
l'ont rendu totalement désespéré.
Je me mets à la place de ma mère.
Si j'avais eu un fils comme moi, et.
Moi de ma propre façon, je me serais taillé les veines.
J'ai eu des pensées vraiment horribles,
Envers ma mère,
Envers mon frère.
J'avais envie qu'il leur arrive des choses. Je pouvais.
Je pouvais faire quelque chose d'horrible.
Je faisais ça pour que ma mère ne m'aime plus,
Pour qu'elle ne puisse plus couler de l'armes
en pensant à moi.
Vous savez dans ma vie, je me suis toujours dit,
La seule façon de tuer l'amour,
c'est de lui donner la mort.
Pas à la personne, mais à son amour qu'elle a pour vous.
C'est fini ma vie, elle est terminée.
Quand est-ce que je vais sortir,
Je ne sortirai plus jamais.
Florent n'a plus de contact avec sa mère.
Elle a fini par baisser les bras.
Le lendemain, tout est redevenu calme.
C'est un matin comme tant d'autres,
Sauf qu'aujourd'hui,
Un patient a un rendez vous qui risque de bouleverser sa vie.
Bonjour Léa !
Avant de pouvoir quitter l'UMD,
Ceux qui ont un statut de détenus doivent avoir
réglé leurs comptes vis à vis de la justice.
Ce matin,
Une juge d'application des peines est venue rencontrer,
Un malade qui a demandé une libération conditionnelle.
Ça va ?
Ouais.
Ce patient, c'est Eric.
Condamné à 20 ans de prison pour actes de barbarie,
Il a déjà passé 15 ans en détention, puis à l'UMD.
Vous vous asseyez en face de moi, je vous prie.
Est-ce que vous voulez que quelqu'un reste avec vous ?
Non c'est bon.
Mais restez là quand même.
Bon alors je reste.
Odile, c'est la cadre de son unité.
Elle a été l'une des premières femmes à travailler à l'UMD.
Pendant toutes ces années, elle l'a accompagné.
Voilà.
Alors on a déjà fait un peu le point
sur votre situation il y a quelques mois,
Par rapport à votre demande de libération conditionnelle.
Et en fin de compte, la semaine dernière,
J'ai su qu'il y a une place
qui vous est réservée très prochainement,
Et que vous allez partir en évaluation.
Vous avez bien compris ?
Avant d'être libéré,
Eric doit partir dans un CNE,
Un centre national d'évaluation.
Ces centres sont situés en prison,
dans des quartiers spécialement aménagés.
Pendant 6 semaines,
Le comportement d'Eric sera observé.
Si tout se passe bien là-bas,
Les médecins pourront décider de le faire sortir
définitivement de l'UMD.
L'étape numéro un,
C'était d'avoir une place pour pouvoir aller
dans ce centre d'évaluation.
Passage obligé, compte tenu des raisons
pour lesquelles vous avez été condamné.
Oui, c'est dans 15 jours.
Il va falloir vous y préparer.
Voilà, voilà Monsieur.
Vous savez comment ça se passe en prison,
Les casquettes, si c'est interdit ou pas ?
Ah pour le CNE ?
Il ne faut pas que ce soit une source d'inquiétude,
À mon avis vous avez des capacités d'adaptation,
Qui vous permettront de vous adapter à ces 6 semaines.
Je pense que sur le plan médical,
Il faut faire confiance à l'équipe qui s'occupe de vous.
Pour commencer à vous apprendre à revivre à l'extérieur.
Ça, c'est déjà une étape essentielle.
Après 11 ans d'UMD,
Eric va peut-être bientôt pouvoir sortir.
Nickel !
Mais il faut d'abord qu'il s'adapte au milieu pénitentiaire.
Odile le sait, ici,
Il a toutes ses habitudes, tous ses repères.
Éric, on va tout préparer.
C'est une bonne nouvelle officieuse,
On va recevoir les papiers.
On va recevoir les papiers,
À partir de là on va organiser au mieux.
Après, la balle est dans votre camp.
C'est vous qui êtes évalué là-bas, d'accord ?
C'est pas nous.
Donc avant de se poser des questions sur les casquettes,
Pour le tabac, pour l'hygiène ?
On va tout organiser avec eux.
D'accord ?
D'accord.
C'est une bonne ?
Nouvelle !
Voilà ! Allez à tout à l'heure,
on en reparle tout à l'heure.
Je suis contente pour lui.
Parce que c'est le bout du tunnel aussi,
Depuis des années quoi.
Ce que je pense de la condamnation,
C'est qu'effectivement ça a été injuste
par rapport à ce patient,
Qui est avant tout, malade.
Donc ce qu'il a fait,
tout aussi affreux que ce soit,
C'était dans un cadre d'une pathologie.
Il a été condamné très lourdement.
Donc bon, là on avance.
Le bout du tunnel approche pour lui,
Bah c'est tant mieux, tant mieux pour lui.
Ben oui, on les aime bien dans tous les cas.
Une fois par an, les ergothérapeutes,
Ici en T-shirt orange,
Organisent une sorte de grande kermesse
dans l'enceinte de l'UMD.
Tous les patients dont l'état le permet y participent.
Ils sont près de 50.
Ce sont les Olympiades,
Un moment que tous attendent avec impatience.
Mais que de monde !
Encadrés par les soignants,
Les malades vont s'affronter pendant une journée
lors de différentes épreuves.
Les équipes ont été tirées au sort parmi les 5 unités.
Pour une fois,
Elles sont mélangées.
Alors je vais faire les présentations :.
Osmane, Philippe, Mickaël, Maxime et Daniel.
D'accord ?
D'accord.
Vous êtes tous motivés ?
Tous ! Bien motivés, on est motivés !
Vous avez la chance de tomber dans une équipe,
Où vous avez eu 2 ans,
Sur les 3 dernières éditions, ce monsieur l'a gagné 2 fois.
L'année dernière je n'ai pas eu de chance,
Je suis arrivé quatrième au classement.
Vous vous rappelez déjà du classement de l'an dernier ?
Oui oui, je m'en rappelle.
Qu'est-ce que je vous ai dit ?
Le plus important, c'est ?
Participer.
Voilà. Ici, il n'y a que des gens qui veulent participer.
Il n'y a pas de gens qui veulent gagner, d'accord ?
Mais je veux gagner moi.
Non, attention Daniel, on est d'accord,
On est pas sûr de gagner.
À l'heure qu'il est, vous êtes pas sûr de gagner ou de perdre !
Oui, ben oui.
Que vous gagnez ou que vous perdez, il faudra l'accepter.
Allez séance d'entraînement,
chacun votre tour vous passez.
L'année dernière, parce qu'il avait perdu,
Daniel était resté prostré pendant des heures.
Allez, suivant, c'est qui le suivant ?
Allez à vous Daniel.
On vise bien !
Oui.
Prenez votre temps.
Aujourd'hui, les soignants vont pouvoir mesurer
les progrès accomplis dans l'année.
Oui, presque !
Vous gagnez en précision !
Et sa façon de gérer sa frustration,
s'il ne gagne pas.
C'est pour tout à l'heure, Daniel.
J'ai fait ce que j'ai pu pourtant.
Eh bien, c'est l'essentiel de faire ce qu'on peut.
C'est l'essentiel.
Merci Nicolas.
Allez-y, le 20 ou le 10 si vous voulez !
Plus qu'une simple compétition,
Les Olympiades permettent aux malades de
travailler sur eux-mêmes en s'amusant.
Allez c'est bien ! Super !
Loin de l'image des fous dits dangereux,
Aujourd'hui ils sont heureux d'être ensemble,
Ça c'est le plaisir de la coupe !
Patients comme soignants,
Et cela se voit.
Quand j'ai connu Daniel,
Le premier jour c'était que de la violence,
Le tout premier jour où on s'est rencontrés.
C'était en 2004, 2005, donc c'était il y a 11 ans.
Aujourd'hui, regardez...
Oui.
Le sourire de Daniel.
Le fruit de notre travail, c'est là qu'on le voit !
C'est quand ils arrivent à faire ces moments là,
C'est quand ils arrivent justement à évoluer.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
C'est là qu'on le voit.
Alors, équipe numéro 7, c'est l'équipe rose !
La journée s'achève avec le palmarès.
Tout le monde gagnera quelque chose,
Tee shirt ou survêtements.
Merci Daniel !
Pour Daniel, c'est la douche froide.
Son équipe n'est que septième
alors qu'il s'est donné à fond.
Dès qu'il est contrarié,
Ses tocs le reprennent et son corps marque sa déception.
Médaille d'argent, l'équipe...
Bleu royal !
Mais cette année,
Ce ne sont pas seulement ceux qui ont brillé
lors des épreuves qui seront récompensés.
Médaille d'or, l'équipe jaune !
Sur le banc, Daniel s'est renfermé et
les soignants l'ont peut-être senti.
Pour leur super esprit d'équipe,
Un prix spécial va être décerné à l'équipe rose !
Est-ce que vous savez pourquoi on vous donne le prix ?
Vous vous êtes encouragés,
Vous avez eu un bon esprit pendant toutes les parties,
Donc voilà, on voulait vous récompenser.
D'un coup, Daniel se redresse.
Alors merci. Merci.
Mais la journée s'achève,
Il est temps pour chacun de retrouver
le quotidien strict de leurs unités.
Salut les enfants, c'est Pimprenelle et Nicolas !
C'est toi Casimir !
Non, moi je suis pas Casimir !
Aurevoir Daniel. Super !
Depuis l'an dernier, Daniel a bien progressé.
Son dépit n'a pas duré et ses médecins estiment,
Qu'il est désormais prêt à franchir de nouvelles étapes,
Peut être même hors de l'UMD.
L'automne approche,
Daniel a rendez-vous à l'hôpital de Cadillac,
Dans l'annexe du tribunal.
Comme tous les 6 mois,
C'est à son tour de passer devant la juge des libertés.
On va mettre une infirmière à côté
parce qu'il est pas très bien aujourd'hui.
Il est ?
Pas très bien aujourd'hui.
Pas très bien, d'accord.
Bonjour maître.
Monsieur ****, vous vous souvenez de moi ?
Oui, vous vous souvenez que je suis Madame le juge ?
Et vous vous souvenez, on s'est vu il y a 6 mois.
Vous n'allez pas très bien aujourd'hui ?
Non, je ne suis pas bien.
J'ai des tocs, je suis pas bien, je suis pas bien dans ma tête.
D'accord.
Il y a quelque chose qui m'a un petit peu surpris,
Parce qu'il y a 6 mois,
Je croyais qu'il était prévu que vous rentriez
bientôt dans votre région d'origine.
Moi je dis non à ça.
D'accord, vous ne voulez plus partir, c'est ça ?
Non, pas pour l'instant, je ne me sens
pas prêt à quitter l'UMD.
J'ai trop de tocs.
Imaginez que je retourne à l'hôpital de Cadillac,
Trois mois plus tard je vais
me retrouver à l'UMD.
Pour violences, pour
violences liées aux tocs.
Vous êtes vraiment pas bien aujourd'hui, effectivement.
Vous voulez qu'on arrête là ?
Je voudrais que vous me souteniez madame.
Votre avocate va parler.
Je suis là pour vous soutenir, ne vous inquiétez pas.
Aujourd'hui, ce qui est sûr,
C'est qu'ici il est dans un cadre sécurisant, contenant,
Et qu'il souhaite effectivement rester, pour le moment,
Dans un but de stabiliser et voir ensuite...
Parce que vous savez au pavillon,
Il y a certaines personnes qui me disent,
Mais quitte donc l'UMD, aie ta liberté à l'extérieur !
Je leur dis : Je fais ce que je veux,
c'est moi que ça regarde,
C'est pas vous que ça regarde !
Malgré tout ce que peuvent vous dire les autres,
Vous, vous préférez rester là
où vous êtes au jour d'aujourd'hui ?
Oui.
D'accord.
Vous vouliez dire autre chose ?
Vous voulez ajouter quelque chose ?
Je ne m'en rappelle plus,
Je ne suis plus dans mon état normal là.
D'accord, c'est pas le jour.
Donc ma décision,
Il y aura bien, que vous vous voulez rester ici,
Et que pour le moment,
C'est le seul endroit où vous vous sentez bien en sécurité.
Oui, c'est le seul endroit où je me sens en sécurité à l'UMD.
Donc vous vous rassurez,
Tant que vous ne demanderez pas à partir,
Il n'y aura pas de changement.
D'accord.
On ne fera rien contre vous.
On fera tout à votre rythme,
Pas au rythme de quelqu'un d'autre.
D'accord, très bien.
Écoutez, je vous souhaite une bonne journée.
Voilà, je vous sens rassuré déjà.
Ça va mieux ?
Bonne journée à vous.
Merci au revoir.
À partir du moment où on est pendant
très longtemps dans un univers qui,
Comme vous avez pu le voir,
c'est quand même assez cocooning.
Je veux dire, tout est fait pour les aider, eux,
À se comprendre, à se maîtriser.
Mais dès lors qu'on est en dehors,
Même si vous avez pu, dans votre carrière,
Voir des détenus sur des maisons centrales,
C'est à dire des gens qui sont incarcérés
depuis de très, très longues années,
On va avoir le même phénomène
quand leur date de sortie approche,
C'est à dire, est-ce que je suis encore adapté ?
Suis-je encore fait pour un monde
qui a continué d'avancer sans moi ?
Suis-je un danger pour les autres ?
On imagine les questionnements des malades.
Dehors,
Ben ils ne sont pas tous gentils les gens,
pas comme ici.
Ici, on est encadrés,
De telle sorte qu'il y a aucune violence.
Dehors de la violence,
il peut y en avoir.
Ça fait peur ?
Dehors, oui un peu.
Je ne suis pas très confiant.
C'est l'inconnu dehors.
Des fois, je me dis,
quand est-ce que je vais sortir ?
Je ne vais pas passé mes 30 ans ici.
Je n'aimerais pas sortir à 30 ans alors
que je vais avoir 25.
Ce serait dur.
Souhaitons que ce ne soit pas trop long,
Que je puisse aller au ski en sortant
sans me casser une jambe.
Je vais au ski à Serre Chevalier si je sors,
Ou à Val Thorens.
Mais on a tous un objectif en commun,
C'est de sortir la tête haute.
Cela fait désormais 2 semaines qu'Eric
a rencontré la juge d'application des peines.
On se dit aurevoir au cas ou ?
Mais non, on se voit demain.
On se voit demain à 14h.
Demain, c'est le jour J.
Il part en prison pour être évalué
et peut être avoir sa liberté conditionnelle.
Avant de quitter l'UMD,
Il voulait dire au revoir à une personne de l'extérieur,
Qu'il voit depuis des années
tous les lundis à la même heure.
Monsieur Lacaze était VRP.
Parce qu'il s'ennuyait à la retraite,
Il a passé l'agrément pour devenir visiteur de prison.
Il est aussi devenu bénévole
auprès des malades de l'UMD.
Je leur amène un petit peu d'air pur de l'extérieur.
Quelques fois, ils me demandent ce qu'il y a autour d'eux.
Je leur dis de la vigne, partout de la vigne.
Il y en a avec qui on discute comme on discute
avec vous en ce moment.
Mais d'autres, il faut leur arracher les mots un petit peu.
Il y en a qui ne répondent que par oui ou par non,
Et qui demandent ma visite.
Il y en a certains, on se tutoie.
J'en vois un qui pourrait être mon fils.
Vous le connaissez, Eric,
Ça fait longtemps qu'il est là, lui.
Tous les patients qui le demandent
peuvent recevoir la visite de Monsieur Lacaze.
Souvent, ce sont ceux qui n'ont plus de famille.
Hormis les blouses blanches et ceux
qui représentent la justice,
Il est la seule personne de l'extérieur qu'ils voient.
Est-ce que c'est impressionnant
la première fois qu'on rentre ici ?
Oui c'est impressionnant, quand vous voyez ce vide.
Vous allez vous rendre compte par vous même.
Ah vous, c'est pas les grilles qui vous impressionnent ?
J'ai l'habitude à force !
Non mais vous voyez, vous arrivez de la rue,
Et puis là, il y a personne.
Sorti de la maison d'arrêt où c'est très bruyant,
Ça a été vraiment le contraste.
Secret médical oblige,
Bonjour Monsieur.
Vous allez bien ?
Monsieur Lacaze ne sait pas pourquoi
les malades sont là.
Lui, ne pose pas de questions.
Il attend qu'ils se confient.
Je vous envoie qui en premier ?
Eric ?
Eric, il s'en va bientôt,
il a des tas de choses à dire.
Ah bon ? Très bien alors.
Eric est le premier patient qu'il a rencontré.
Bonjour Eric, ça va ?
Ça va.
Ils se connaissent depuis 7 ans.
Alors raconte moi depuis lundi dernier.
T'as commencé à faire ta valise ?
C'est fait, c'est fait.
Mes valises sont faites.
Ça va faire bizarre ce soir.
Tous les repères que j'ai ici, je vais les quitter.
Et puis c'est le carcéral, ils vont me mettre nu,
Ils vont fouiller mes affaires.
C'est dur ça.
Mais oui, mais bon, c'est qu'une fois,
c'est qu'à l'arrivée,
C'est la porte pour la liberté ça.
Oh oui! C'est un pas de géant pour moi.
Et là vous êtes prêt ?
J'ai toujours été prêt,
Depuis le premier jour.
Bon séjour là-bas, et puis reviens nous.
Je t'écris.
D'accord. Aurevoir Eric.
Je laisse la porte ouverte.
D'accord. Merci.
Eric, c'est un peu spécial.
Je ne sais pas si je lui ai apporté quelque chose,
Mais j'ai vu sa santé s'améliorer.
Pour être, comme vous l'avez vu aujourd'hui.
Donc ça, ça ne s'oublie pas.
Il était comment la première fois ?
La première fois,
il me regardait avec des yeux comme ça,
Et puis il tremblait, il me regardait, il faisait ça...
Puis il ne souriait pas.
Vous connaissez son histoire ?
Oui, il me l'a racontée.
C'est dommage.
Parce que ça devait être un mec bien.
C'est bon, là, il y a tout.
Il y a tout.
Pour la première fois depuis 11 ans,
Eric ne dormira pas à l'UMD.
C'est bon pour les papiers ?
Oui.
Il va découvrir sa nouvelle cellule.
J'avais le trac oui,
je ne savais pas où j'allais.
Ça s'est fait à une vitesse en plus, c'était l'éclair !
Ça fait bizarre, non ?
Oui je ne sais pas où je vais.
Les infirmiers ont peur pour moi,
je suis fragile encore.
Ils pensent que je suis fragile,
Mais ça ne me fait pas peur.
Il y a un bonhomme là-bas,
je ne sais pas si c'est un gardien.
Mais oui, je sais pas.
Ces bonshommes,
Ce sont les agents de la pénitentiaire
qui viennent chercher Eric,
Pour l'emmener à 600 km en banlieue parisienne.
Votre date de naissance, c'est ?
Quand on est confronté à la pénitentiaire,
on sait ce qui nous attend.
Les menottes, les entraves.
On ne peut pas faire autrement.
On doit se plier à la discipline.
Ça va bien se passer. D'accord Eric ?
Désormais, il devra gérer sa maladie tout seul.
J'ai trop envie de pouvoir,
me donner les moyens pour m'en sortir,
Devenir quelqu'un.
Je rêve de refaire ma vie.
Cela fait maintenant 10 mois que nous sommes
arrivés pour la première fois à Cadillac.
Pour ceux qui sont loin de leur famille,
L'approche de Noël,
C'est toujours un moment compliqué.
Cette histoire de Noël, tout le monde la connaît,
C'est la naissance de Jésus.
Celui qui est venu sur la terre
pour sauver tout le monde.
Dans cette petite célébration toute simple de Noël
qu'on fait ici à l'UMD,
On vient dire merci Jésus, merci Seigneur.
Merci Jésus, merci Seigneur.
Et on vient lui confier aussi nos soucis, nos peines.
Allez, on va se mettre debout.
Tous les ans, le prêtre de la paroisse
vient dire la messe.
Tous ceux qui le souhaitent, peuvent y assister.
Aujourd'hui catholiques ou non,
Ils sont une cinquantaine à prier tous ensemble.
C'est aussi notre dernier jour de tournage.
Depuis, nous avons pris des nouvelles des patients.
Philippe vient de recevoir l'aval
des médecins pour quitter l'UMD.
Plus tard, il voudrait devenir bénévole
dans une association caritative.
Toujours délirant,
Michel devrait bientôt aussi quitter Cadillac,
Pour rejoindre une autre unité pour
malades difficiles à Albi.
Le corps du Christ.
Là-bas, une cousine s'est manifestée.
Et elle pourra lui rendre visite.
Jean-pierre se bat toujours pour quitter l'UMD.
Mais son souci du moment,
C'est qu'on l'autorise de nouveau à teindre ses cheveux.
Pour voir si Daniel était capable
de s'adapter à un nouvel environnement,
On l'a changé de pavillon.
Ça faisait 12 ans qu'il était dans la même unité.
C'est ma chambre.
Son transfert s'est bien passé.
Il s'habitue à sa nouvelle chambre
et peu à peu, ses tocs s'apaisent.
Tu vois, il y a 20 ans,
tu serais resté longtemps sur ta clé.
Punaise, oui !
Tu serais resté longtemps, tu vois que tu t'es amélioré !
Quant à Eric, il est sorti de prison.
Il a obtenu sa liberté conditionnelle,
Et aujourd'hui, il retrouve sa mère.
Ça va ?
Ça me fait plaisir que tu sois là.
Il est toujours soigné à l'hôpital
psychiatrique de Cadillac,
Mais il pourra bientôt sortir le week-end.
Je vais pouvoir commencer une nouvelle vie.
C'est motivant.
On s'accroche.
Quand il aura trouvé une place
dans un centre pour travailleurs handicapés,
Il pourra sortir complètement de l'hôpital.
En France, 1% de la population serait schizophrène,
Mais seule une infime minorité se retrouve
dans des unités pour malades difficiles.
La plupart ne passent jamais à l'acte,
Ils trouvent leur place dans la société.